[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the
bloodlines of the wizarding world
more specifically we're going to be
honing in on and discussing muggleborns
also known as mudbloods to the darker
more sinister side of the wizarding
world
now before we dive too far into this
topic let me first establish that blood
status is one of the most controversial
aspects of the wizarding world a concept
in which wizarding families can be
distinguished by the level of magically
endowed family members
generally speaking people are
slaughtered into one of the following
categories pure blood half blood or
muggle
with the special term muggleborn
referring to a witch or wizard with two
non-magical parents the existence of
such a system however brings nothing to
the wizarding world but hatred and
prejudice
acting in a very similar fashion to race
in the real world in fact one of the
main focuses of voldemort's regime was
establishing power of the worlds of
half-bloods and mughals
voldemort felt that those with pure
bloodlines deserved to be in power and
he also grew increasingly concerned that
pure blood numbers would dwindle while
the number of muggleborns climbed
effectively extinguishing pure blood
from the wizarding world
and as it turns out voldemort was very
right to have that fear as statistics
show that the number of muggleborns
climbs year over year
with that said let me get to the meat of
today's video
which is a list of all known muggleborns
that is witches or wizards born to
muggle parents that we know of in the
wizarding world i'm going to start with
the more obvious ones and make my way
toward the less obvious ones that you
may not know about
how many do you know of comment below
before we get started
1. hermione granger hermione granger was
a muggle-born witch born in 1979 to
muggle parents mr and mrs granger
interestingly enough hermione didn't
realize that she was in fact a witch
until she received her hogwarts letter
at the age of 11.
hermione was the first magical person in
her family and went on to have two
half-blood children with ron weasley
2. lily evans lily potter born lily
evans was an english muggle-born witch
born in the year 1960 to muggle parents
mr and mrs evans
most notably she was the husband of
james potter and mother of harry potter
lily's most notable and most impressive
accomplishment to date was her loving
sacrifice which allowed harry potter to
live simultaneously killing voldemort at
least temporarily it's also worth
mentioning that lilly's sister petunia
was not magical despite having the same
parentage
3. kendra dumbledore kendra dumbledore
was a muggle-born witch born in the year
1850
kendra is perhaps best known as the
mother of famous hogwarts headmaster
albus dumbledore and wife of percival
dumbledore
tragically kendra was killed by her
daughter ariana in a freak accident in
which she lost control of her magic
4. moaning myrtle myrtle warren aka
moaning myrtle was a muggle-born witch
born in either 1928 or 1929.
myrtle attended hogwarts from 1940 to
1943
some of the same years as voldemort and
was eventually killed in 1943 by
slytherin's basilisk under tom riddle's
orders
after the incident she became a ghost
who haunted the second floor girl's
bathroom 5. edward tonks ted tonks
edward ted tonks was a muggle-born
wizard born in an unknown year to muggle
parents
he is known for marrying andromeda black
a pure blood witch from the house of
black and fathering nymphadoratox
because ted was a muggleborn andromeda's
family scorned her
ted's grandson teddy the son of
nymphadora and remus was named after him
6. justin finch fletchley justin finch
fletchley was a muggle-born wizard born
in the year 1980
notably he was in the same year as harry
at hogwarts
during his time at hogwarts justin
joined dumbledore's army an organization
taught and led by harry potter he said
this when first meeting harry
my name was down for eaton you know i
can't tell you how glad i am i came here
instead
of course mother was slightly
disappointed but since i made her read
lockhart's books i think she's begun to
see how useful it'll be to have a fully
trained wizard in the family
7. colin cravey
colin cravey was a muggle-born wizard
born in the year 1981 to parents mr
creefy and mrs cravey
colin was the older brother of dennis
gravy
colin was a big fan of harry potter and
was known to take photos of him as well
as other students at hogwarts school
colin was expelled from hogwarts in his
sixth year due to voldemort's policy of
not allowing muggleborns to attend the
school
and in may of 1998 he was murdered by
death eaters 8. dennis creevy
dennis gravy was a muggle-born wizard
born in the year 1983 two parents mr and
mrs creavy he was the younger brother of
colin creevy
dennis was a gryffindor and while
studying at hogwarts he joined
dumbledore's army
9. dirk cresswell
dirk creswell is a muggle-born wizard
that became head of the goblin liaison
office in the ministry of magic
during the ministry takeover by lord
voldmort cresswell attempted to hide his
heritage by forging a family tree
however he was later found out
cresswell was eventually murdered by
snatchers while on the run 10. mary
catamol
mary elizabeth catamol was a british
mughal-born witch
little is known about mary but she plays
a role in the story when she is being
interrogated by dolores umbridge at the
muggleborn registration commission trial
during the ministry takeover 11. donahan
tremlet donahan tremlet was a
muggle-born wizard and fairly minor
character
known only for playing bass in the
popular wizarding band
the weird sisters
12. mrs ollivander mrs ollivander was a
muggle-born witch who with her husband
gervais ollivander raised known wand
maker garrick olivander
garrick eventually took over the family
wand making business in diagon alley 13.
nobby leech nobby leach was a
muggle-born wizard and the british
minister for magic between 1962 and
1968.
he was notably the first muggle-born
minister for magic to ever hold office
he left his post in 1968 after
contracting a serious illness which many
speculate was the work of abraxas malfoy
14. kevin and whistle
kevin end whistle was a muggle-born
wizard born in 1979 to muggle parents
he was in the same year as harry potter
and was sorted into either hufflepuff or
ravenclaw house kevin was listed on
rowling's draft class list as a
muggleborn however some believe that
this is not true canon due to
contradictions with the novels 15.
johannes yonker
yonker was an american muggle-born
wizard born in 1909 or earlier
along with shikoba wolf thiago quintana
and violetta bouvey yonker was one of
four wand makers who served north
america in the early 20th century
yonker's father was a successful cabinet
maker which presumably gave him the
woodworking experience to become a
skilled wand maker and that concludes
the list of known muggleborns however
there are some honorable mentions that i
want to include the first honorable
mention is hannah abbott i know what
you're thinking isn't hannah a half
blood well there's more to it than that
you see as it turns out hannah abbott
was originally listed as a muggleborn on
jk rowling's draft list of students in
harry potter's class
however rowling later contradicted
herself in an interview where she stated
that she always considered hannah to be
a pureblood
to compromise hannah was officially made
a half-blood the next honorable mention
goes to terry boot
terry boot like hannah abbott was listed
as a muggleborn on rowling's draft class
list
however in harry potter and deathly
hallows boot was shown to be attending
his seventh year at hogwarts despite
muggleborns being banned from the school
while lord voldemort was in power this
would suggest that boot is likely not a
muggleborn
unless of course he successfully faked
his family tree to remain at the school
and that's it for this video it's
entirely possible that i may have missed
someone so if you see a name or family
missing from this list then please
comment it down below
also did you know all of these
muggleborns were there more or less than
you expected until next time remember
words are in my not so humble opinion
our most inexhaustible source of magic
[Music]
you